left evangelical movement because of
rigidity of dogma now fellow
progressives remind me of same in their
insistence I work on my racism and not
challenge black voices had any success
and changing anyone's mind friends have
good intentions of course intentions
don't matter so just at this they were
just trying to save characters to get
the question in this person left the
evangelical movement because of the
rigidity of dogmas aaron is now finding
a similar virginity in the ideology of
the left yeah I think it's even worse
than that I was reading a subreddit and
somebody posted a comment about the
frightening situation that they faced
this was somebody who had come to the
u.s. from abroad from a a country with a
dictatorial regime and their point was
my family has seen this before yeah I
don't know what to do it's very
frightening I know what it is but people
who haven't seen it before don't know
what it is and they're falling prey to
it and anyway that's alarming yeah and
the comments that followed that comment
also reflected other parts of the world
in which people have seen this and their
descendants who are now here are
recognizing the analogy and people are
rightly concerned about it I also
detected something in this thread that I
thought was pretty important something I
had never put together before which was
that the communism that happened in the
Soviet Union resulted in slavery by a
different name that effectively rural
people were enslaved to create the
productivity that kept the Soviet Union
going and I never put that together
right I knew it was terrible but I
didn't understand that basically they
had reinvented slavery as a mechanism to
make that civilization work and I'm not
sure that's very far off from the Great
Leap Forward either no it's in the
sixties early Maoist China so in some
sense I guess what I'm saying is to the
extent that this movement imagines that
what it is is the final complete
uninvent of slavery it may be the
reinvention of slavery and that that is
something that we have to try
very carefully
[Music]